when you say I can stop this you don't L
do you literally mean you personally can
stop or no you're saying that God can
stop this and you can be an instrument
you know what is the difference between
that occultism and where we are now when
I was in the occultism I had the power I
could do it the way I wanted when I
wanted I didn't have to ask any I would
just do it my spirit guide will help me
to do it now I am a Christian I don't do
anything that's not Guided by the Holy
Spirit if it's not Guided by the Holy
Spirit I'm not doing it so when I say
like we have the power to do it through
Jesus Christ we are the vessels we are
the instrument and this is the same way
that the enemy is looking for people
that live in sin to advance his kingdom
is the same way that God is looking for
holy people to advance his kingdom so if
you see it follows kind of like the same
principle God is looking for Holy
vessels who are going to S to surrender
to him to live in Holiness so he can use
it to advance his kingdom the same way